what's the most difficult part about  being a nurse to me a nurse must deliver  the work of a contractor that is quick  professional and effective while at the  same time giving love and compassion a  nurse may be going through a divorce has  recently lost a loved one lost a patient  or be overworked due to short staffing  it is at times when I am pulled and  stretched from every angle that I  remember the importance of self-care to  take a step back and breathe slowly to  talk to someone to pray to allow  yourself to cry and process emotions or  all of the above  you cannot give from an empty cup  so take time to make sure your cup is  full every day so that you can give your  best to those around you and yourself as  well